Joe Rogan: Yeah, that's
what I'm talking about!
Look at him!
[crunching]
Narrator: That sound
isn't really the sound
of a cockroach being chewed.
It's actually something
much more familiar:
the sound of crunching M&M's.
[crunching]
You'd think the sounds in a reality show
like "Fear Factor" would be, well, real,
but they're created by Foley artists
like Monique Reymond.
Monique has worked on her fair share
of reality competition shows,
each of which has its own array of sounds,
ranging from outrageous...
[punching]
[water splashing]
to subtle.
[clinking]
But the real challenge is
creating the perfect balance
between realism and exaggeration.
Monique Reymond: How did that sound?
Narrator: Reality game shows
use Foley artists to
create their sound effects
because it is often too complicated
to record high-quality sound
while filming those shows.
And by using Foley,
these artists can add
dramatics to the show.
There are some instances,
like with "Wipeout,"
when exaggeration is
actually the whole point.
[crashing]
Monique: We would, for each show,
do every punching glove and every impact.
And the thing is, something like that,
with production sound,
there's probably no impact at all.
The glove just probably comes out,
and the person falls off into the water.
In order to make that
a more entertaining journey
for people to experience visually,
we would add a little bit of smack
to make it seem more
funny and more dramatic
and more interesting for people.
Narrator: To create that extra smack,
[smacking]
Monique adds leafy greens
on top of the foam mat,
creating an extra little
crunch to each hit.
However, some reality
game shows require Foley
that is a bit more realistic,
like "American Gladiators."
The foam-mat hits
aren't embellished with any extra crunch,
and the clinking of metal harnesses
adds some reality.
[clinking]
But in shows like "Fear Factor,"
the fine balance between
reality and dramatization
really comes into play.
Monique: It's almost as
if, like, when you're in
a situation where you're nervous
and you can almost hear your heartbeat,
you don't really hear your heartbeat,
but you feel it, right?
Well, so that's what we
try to do with the Foley
with these kinds of shows.
Narrator: Creepy bugs are a
mainstay for "Fear Factor,"
[contestant yells]
so Monique had to figure out
how to create an array
of squeamish bug noises.
Unlike crunchy cockroaches,
a bowl full of worms is created
by using an old car shammy.
Monique: So, we soak
them in a tub of water.
This is where the magic happens,
because they get really soft.
And once these guys get soft,
they can take on a life
of so many different handy things.
And this is gonna be perfect for worms.
So, for when we do the
worms just kind of gushing,
we're gonna just add a
little bit of moisture,
make them sound even grosser.
[squishing]
Oh, yeah, that's nice.
Narrator: And even the same type of bug
can make different sounds
depending on the situation.
Creating Foley for a
tub full of cockroaches
is completely different
from crunching a cockroach.
Monique: Sometimes you
nail sounds immediately.
Other times you just have to work with it.
And with the aquarium full of roaches,
the roach has kind of a
firm exoskeletal situation.
Like, what would sound like those shells?
What we came up with rather quickly
was pistachios,
but then that didn't really work.
The pistachios sounded too small
and almost too even.
And so then we added Brazil nuts,
then we added peanuts,
and that wasn't even quite it.
And then you think about it,
and what is the most creepy part
of being surrounded with bugs
is having them crawl on you.
So we were missing the
creepiness of the crawling.
And so then we experimented
on a little pine cone
so that we could get that feeling
of being crawled upon,
like these things are under your clothes.
Narrator: While Monique had figured out
the noises for the cockroaches,
something still didn't
sound totally accurate
when the cockroaches were initially poured
into the tub with a contestant.
So she had to adapt her Foley once again
to make sure that it sounded just right.
Monique: Since there's somebody in there,
if I just were to pour
this into the plastic tub,
it wouldn't sound like
there was a body in there.
So I added some gloves in here.
If that's not quite enough,
I might stick a leather jacket in, too.
[nuts clattering]
Narrator: Monique says
that creating the realistic
balance of these sounds for "Fear Factor"
was especially difficult
because sometimes she had no reference
for what a noise sounded like.
Monique: There was a specific
episode of "Fear Factor"
where somebody had to eat sheep eyes
versus Buffalo testicles.
I don't know what either
sound would be, fortunately,
but, I don't know, if we were just to bite
into something that was soft and gushy,
that would probably be
what it sounded like.
But to exaggerate it,
to make it a little bit more horrific,
we decided to use cherry tomatoes
because there was that little popping.
There was that skin on the outside,
and there's that little
explosion of the tomato.
We wanted this to sound
a little bit more upsetting.
And Foley grounds this
in reality for people,
because if it was all music and score,
that might drive
the drama of the situation,
the suspense of the situation,
but it's not gonna creep you out.
Narrator: Now, game shows
aren't the only thing she's worked on,
but Monique has kind of
developed a reputation
as one of Hollywood's go-to Foley artists
for reality competitions.
Monique: I worked on "Mad
Men" for a few seasons.
What a beautifully written,
acted, stylized show.
Now, for Foley,
briefcase,
hats,
glass of scotch,
tinkle some ice.
All fine and well,
but there is no opportunity
for imagining what a
maggot would sound like.
I have found creating Foley
for game shows to be actually
much more satisfying than
I would have imagined.